so it's a conflict of groups and these
groups are unequal and respecting other
people's freedom to do what they want
with their lives and tolerating
differences that's just completely alien
the world is seen as a dark place of
conflict and it's either your group is
going to prevail or my group is going to
prevail
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people a fascinating guest we have for
you today we are delighted to say that
we're joined once again by one of our
favorite ever guests professor stephen
hicks welcome back to trigonometry hey
thanks guys it was a real pleasure last
time so appreciate the reinvitation
it was a real pleasure last time we
talked of course about post-modernism
you explained where it comes from where
it's going and so on but
i was saying to you uh in our emails
about coming back on that we here at the
studio were watching a documentary you
made as you explained about 20 years ago
i must confess the production values
that reflect the fact that it was 20
years ago but
pre-hd in the video world so yeah
quite but nonetheless despite that it
was a documentary you made about
nietzsche and the nazis and in that you
talked about what motivated the nazis
what motivated the people who supported
the nazis uh how that is misunderstood
and of course some of the philosophers
who inspired some of the things that
they did and also the differences
between them but the real reason that we
wanted to talk to you about that is you
know
the nazis in in the discourse at least
they're back there's a nazi around every
corner they're on the rise if you're on
this side of the political spectrum and
they people people talk about it in the
context of covet now of course and all
of that so
can you talk to us about first of all
one of the things that really struck me
in that documentary is you talked about
the fact that the ideas that motivated
the nazis they saw themselves as heroic
they saw themselves as doing something
for the greater good can you just give
us because i think it will be a shocking
perspective to many people in the modern
world can you give us a a flavor of what
their ideas were why they believed they
were doing the right thing what drove
them
yeah
yeah that's an important question i mean
comparisons to fascists and nazis and so
on are all over the place in
contemporary discourse
and uh we should be trying to learn from
history and those comparisons can be
made but we do have to of course be very
careful in in how we do it that's you
know dropping the hand grenade into the
conversation
and uh
it needs to be it needs to be
contextualized but yes one of the
interesting thing is the one that you're
you're flagging here that we
uh have this image of the nazis as thugs
and as brutes and as just the most evil
uh people almost in in all of human
history
and uh they were thugs they were brutes
and this was a mass movement and so
there's a huge number of people in the
movement who are are operating on on
that low level of
of humanity or or anti-humanity
but i think it's a mistake just to write
off the nazis particularly the
intellectuals the activists the
politicians merely as brutes and thugs
as as amoral individuals that when you
read the literature they did see
themselves as idealists and the hard
thing for us
particularly those of us raised on
western civilization with a very
different set of ideals is to
understand that there are people who can
have dramatically different philosophies
of life
including an understanding of what is
good what is bad what is uh moral
character who the good guys are who the
bad guys are and really believe it and
be strongly committed to realizing those
values in in the world it's a
philosophical uh uh collision that comes
out in political battles and then
ultimately in
in war like battles uh but unfortunately
uh most people don't uh get enough
philosophical education to
realize the values that under undermine
or animate their own civilization they
kind of have a sort of understanding of
them they pick it up through through
osmosis much less uh being taught the
major competitive value frameworks and
really get inside them and to see how
someone raised in a very different
culture could come to believe completely
different sorts of things so we talked
about hitler and goebbels and guring and
hess and and all of these guys and they
were politicians uh initially they were
they were activists but my focus
as a philosopher and as an academic is
to say these guys didn't just uh pop out
of nowhere any time you are going to
rise to the top
in an educated philosophical nation like
germany especially and in the 1920s the
germans were the most educated people in
the world they thought of themselves as
the most cultured people in the world
and there's a lot of
evidence that they can cite in order in
order to support that and it's not just
that millions and millions of people
voted for the nazis uh you know from all
walks of life it's also the case that
mainstream intellectuals even
intellectuals at the top of their
professions uh germany was a highly
philosophical nation a german philosophy
especially had the highest reputation
around the world at that time you get a
phd from a german university that means
something you get a phd from a german
university in a in philosophy to use one
of our metaphors you are a rock star
right just you know in the same way that
we now know
you guys are british so you probably
follow the the football over there
you know who all of the main names in in
football right and you know who are the
the second tier ones are and you know a
lot about their personal lives and so on
that's what it was like to be a
high-profile academic in in germany at
the at the time and the fact is that
the uh
the
phds and phds who were professors were
widely supportive of the nazis not only
after the nazis came to power and then
you might say well after they come to
power people are are cowards or people
want the goodies that the politicians
can can distribute to them but before
the nazis came to power in the 1920s
the brightest stars in the german
academic world many of them are on board
with some
philosophical ideological variation of
the national socialist program
and then pushing things back even even
further uh
all of them
are are educated hitler read
voluminously he knew his kant he knew
his hegel he knew his marks he knew
friedrich nietzsche anybody now around
the world if you are getting a
first-rate education in the humanities
you know something about kant hegel
marks nietzsche uh these were not
unintellectual thugs they were well read
goebbels had a phd
uh uh and and was widely educated at
several universities around you and
that's just the politician activist so
they had heavy duty support now the
thing then is and this is uh where it
becomes very difficult is
you know if we're an educated person now
in the early part of the 21st century
we've heard of nietzsche of course we've
heard of marx maybe we've heard of hegel
maybe we've heard of kant uh uh but
maybe we can't put too much together but
the point is going to be that there is a
philosophical universe that was staked
out by the most brilliant intellectuals
almost of all time
uh all of them german philosophers and
the reason why they were so influential
and are still so influential two
centuries later is because of their
brilliance and the power of their
arguments and that's not to say whether
the arguments are right or wrong it's
that they are brilliant they are deep
they are shaping the entire intellectual
culture of germany in the 1800s and uh
they believed themselves to be
high moralists and deep thinkers the
inheritors of all of the great cultural
traditions and pointing the direction
toward the future they haven't worked
out and of course what comes along then
is idealistic and ambitious and
energetic young people and enter
regeneration they want to reform their
society to make it to to make it better
they want their own lives to be
meaningful they turn in their culture to
their most famous philosophers they read
them they absorb them then they go into
law they go become teachers they become
journalists they become medical doctors
they become parents they shape a culture
and the point is going to be that the
philosophical groundwork by germany's
deepest thinkers was laid for the
national socialist it was a
philosophical movement it saw itself as
an idealistic movement and they were uh
very effective also at organizing and
doing the nitty-gritty of politics and
then successful in the in the political
sphere now the point of contrast is
going to be for you know so use some
examples since you guys are british but
i was born and raised in canada so we're
we're kind of like the you know the
little brothers
culturally speaking so to sort of you
i'm now working in the united states but
the the biggest names that most of us
will have heard of are going to be
people like john locke
and adam smith and john stuart mill and
if you're an educated person
then these are the guys that you read
and you read them deeply and you read
the two treatises of government and on
the wealth of nations and on liberty and
it becomes part of your your
intellectual furniture and you come to
believe that some sort of liberalism
broadly construed is deeply decent and
moral and we need to have moral fervor
to reform all of the ill liberal uh
cultural traditions that have come down
to make society a better place and we
become committed as cultural activists
and political but the idea is that we
are channeling john locke and adam smith
and and and john stewart mill and so on
and we think that we are right and the
point is going to be uh in this at that
level you know that john locke and
emmanuel kant
uh adam smith and someone like karl marx
and uh
nietzsche and someone like john stuart
mill entirely different philosophical
universes it's a collision of
philosophies a collision of values and
then
one of the things that happens of course
by the time we get to the 20 20th
century is uh
that collision of philosophies becomes a
collision in the trenches right so i
mean there's a reason why
the french and the and the english had
their guns pointed at the germans and
the germans had their guns pointed at
the other way and so on uh so
the roots are deep and we do ourselves i
think a disservice if we don't
uh take the ideas seriously however
repugnant the ideas are if we just say
oh they're just a bunch of thugs or they
were just uh lucky somehow and uh we're
able to fool a lot of people uh
the
the philosophy is hard but it's
important
stephen don't you think that the reason
we call them thugs the reason that we
call them brutes is we do actually the
same thing with people like sex
offenders and rapists and pedophiles
where we go these people are monsters
they're nothing like us we dehumanize
them by going they're knocking look
they're nothing like us therefore
they're different to us therefore i'm
never going to be capable of those
particular acts whether they're nazis
whether they're rapists etc no that's
exactly right your moral framework is
absolutely important uh you know what
standard you use to say this is good and
this is bad and then when you apply that
to other human beings those human beings
that you see who are most assaulting
your standard of the good and most
embodying your standard of the bad those
people you see them as less than human
so the dehumanizing languages is very
important and once you see them as
dehumanizing then you think it's
appropriate for me to start treating
them with less than fully human respect
and then that goes all the way down to i
am willing to put these people in prison
and or i am willing to kill these people
so
the establishment of your standards of
right and wrong that's a very difficult
high-level philosophical project becomes
absolutely important because ultimately
that's going to be the basis for your
laws that's going to be the basis for
the circumstances under which you are
willing to fight other people either
aggressively or or self-defensively what
does your life mean uh and uh you are
going to
be willing to kill
uh ultimately people you think are are
evil and you're going to think that
you're doing it in in a good cause
because you are upholding your standard
of value
and stephen you talk about the clash of
values and value systems and i think
that's really where where this is
important because uh one of the values
it seems to me of of the western liberal
project which we obsess about almost to
our fault now is the idea of equality
and the philosophers that motivated and
whose work the nazis relied on were
explicitly
from a different way of looking at the
whole issue can you talk a little bit
about that oh yeah absolutely
so
so the the concept of equality of course
is a rich one but in that liberal
tradition we also have the values of
liberty
the values of individuality
uh we expect that people as individuals
uh free to run their own lives their
their own romantic lives their sex lives
their their artistic lives their
business lives and so on so all of this
liberty and we think that everyone
should have that liberty correctly but
then we recognize that since people are
individuals they're going to
have different
secondary values and make different
choices and the universe is complicated
and so we're going to have different
ways of conceptualizing it and so on but
if your bottom line is the liberty of
individuals and that's an equal
principle that should be extended to all
human beings then tolerance becomes a
very important social value as well so
those uh form a bedrock network as i see
it in the in the in the liberal
tradition and the idea is that of course
we're going to have our differences with
each other but by and large uh people
are decent and uh you know if you go off
and you do your thing in the artistic
sphere you're likely to come up with
some creative you know artistic things
and uh you you'll be fulfilling yourself
but i'm going to enjoy reading your
novels or listening to your songs and so
on or you might be a little bit of a
weird uh you know eccentric inventor
kind of guy and you're going to go off
and make some sort of a gizmo and i
don't really know what you're doing but
it's and it's kind of weird but
ultimately you're going to be making
something i'm going to say oh that's
cool that can benefit my life and so i'm
going to be willing to give you some
money in order to have one of those
gizmos so the idea is that
we will live and let live but if we live
and let live people are going to go off
and do interesting things that are
ultimately going to benefit themselves
and then then us and of course if i
don't like your kind of music or the
gizmo that you're made i'm free not to
buy it and so on and destroy it on
twitter as well
well yes
so the the free speech element uh
absolutely even if that's going to get a
little bit a little bit nasty but
there's a kind of benevolence in that
that ultimately we're going to have a
peaceful society and we're going to uh
be doing a win-win trade now if you then
reject all of that fundamentally
the equality the liberal the
the liberal
freedoms
the idea of tolerance even the idea that
people are first and foremost
individuals you're going to enter into a
very different philosophical space and
so what we find in the in the 19th
century
particularly in thinkers like hegel and
marx and nietzsche is a very deep
assault on all of those liberal values
for all of them first and foremost
people are not individuals
they are all of them seeing people as
born into
various sorts of cultural groups and
that those cultural groups have their
own internal dynamic that is completely
different from other cultural groups
and those uh cultural groups they can't
understand each other really they they
have completely different values that
are antithetical to each other so they
are not only unequal but they're also
not really individuals all of us really
are just members of these different
groups with completely different values
and those values are so antagonistic
that any sort of tolerance uh just seems
as it seems
impossible as well so it's a conflict of
groups and these groups are unequal and
respecting other people's freedom to do
what they want with their lives and
tolerating differences that's just
completely alien the world is seen as a
dark place of conflict and it's either
your group is going to prevail or my
group is going to prevail and so to
speak all's fair in this bottom line
by abstract the world is not
fundamentally fair the world is
fundamentally conflict and whoever has
the most power is going to dominate so i
i just want to you know cite for you
know many of us who have our
undergraduate brushing up against
thinkers like hegel and marx and
nietzsche that all of them are
violent conflict theorists all of them
say explicitly that individuals belong
to the group they have different ideas
of what that group is that individuals
should be serving the group that
individuals can be uh used by the group
sacrificed by the group and if you are
in an out group you are a fundamental
mortal enemy and anything can be done to
uh to destroy the out group enemy uh and
that is the inheritance of
20 early 20th century german
intellectual life and the nazis are just
a particularly effective player of that
cultural framework
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website well if you do then easy
dns are the company for you easy dns is
the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be council culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows a bit about
that so will you in a second easy dns of
rock-solid network infrastructure and
incredible customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you'd know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is head over to easydns.com forward
slash triggered and use our promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get 50 off with the initial
purchase sign up for their newsletter
access of easy that tells you everything
you need to know about technology
privacy and censorship
stephen so
we're talking right now and to me it
strikes me as dare i say a very
darwinian way of looking at the world in
that there are winners and there's
losers and that you have to strive you
have to be the best in order to defeat
your rivals in order to get to the top
of the hierarchy yeah
sure
yeah so at that level of abstraction yes
and and that being the case
they're called nazis national socialists
what does that mean were they actually
socialists were they actually right-wing
were they left-wing or was it its own
philosophy entirely
yeah
well that's uh good so then we get into
all of the great debates about what is a
socialist really and uh you know so it's
like we've had long centuries of debates
about what's a christian really or
what's a liberal really and so on so i'm
happy to jump into into into that debate
but let me say that the uh the nazis
uh as a short form for national
socialist german workers party is the
full name uh of the party the party was
originally founded in
1919
by uh
this was before hitler joined the party
uh and it was called the german workers
party
and as that name suggests it says we are
in favor of the workers against all of
the other classes in society and it is
this zero-sum adversarial struggle and
they saw themselves as a as a as a
revolutionary party they were
anti-capitalist
they thought that the government was uh
in the pocket of the big bankers and
most of the big bankers of course were
jews from their perspective uh and that
the way capitalism and free markets work
allegedly is in terms of liberty and so
on but really it's just the rich
exploiting the poor
they're charging interest and living up
parasitically off the interests of other
people so all of this is worked out as
an ideology and at that level it sounds
like a very
left-wing ideology and all of the early
members of the party were very well read
in in karl marx uh adolf hitler in 1919
goes to a big rally and here's a speech
by gottfried fader one of the one of the
founders and and intellectuals of the
movement very impressed with this guy
uh and then he on the basis of being
inspired by this speech decides to join
the party in in in 1919 now what you
have then is a what sounds like a
left-wing socialist version of class
warfare adversarialism anti-capitalism
and that was part of hitler's background
now the other part though then is
the anti-jew
anti-gypsy anti-black people basically
anti-anybody who doesn't fit our
understanding of what the best kind of
human being is and that's another kind
of collectivism that then is to say it's
not so much economic groups that are in
this
brutal conflict with each other but it's
ethnic groups and it's racial groups and
it's religious groups and so on and
there's all various uh mixes of that
that's going on uh and i you know we
happen to be a part of this group and we
have within our midst all of these other
subgroups that really should not be a
part of this overall community that we
are thinking of as as germany and this
is the nationalism part of the of the
program and it says from that
perspective economic matters are part of
the package but they're only one part of
the package we're more interested in
cultures and societies as a whole you
know their language their traditions
their their religions their racial
groups and so forth along with all of
their economic arrangements as well now
the point of this is that this is
sometimes seen as a as a more right-wing
approach to doing political views and
that's that's fine in a european context
but what is important here is that that
also is a collectivism it is also saying
individuals are not free agents
individuals don't have their own lives
liberties pursuit of happiness and all
of that sort of thing individuals are
part of
ethnic groups or individuals are part of
racial groups just as the people on the
left are saying no individuals really
are part of economic groups and both of
them then are saying there is no
individualism individualism is totally
shaped by and should be submerged to
various groups and so what the nazis are
doing you know you might say this is
very clever as a political move but they
also believed it truly is to say uh we
believe both are correct
it is an economic clash it is a racial
clash it is a religious clash and so on
we need to put it together and that is
why they renamed the party in 1920 to
the national
socialist german workers party and they
took the nationalism seriously in this
collectivistic fashion they took the
socialism seriously in this uh
collectivistic fashion and they did see
themselves still on the side of the of
the of the german workers now at this
point hitler had become a serious mover
and shaker in the in the party he was a
highly energetic guy
uh he was very well read very well read
for for a politician
uh uh even if we you know would disagree
with just about everybody he was reading
uh and then uh
with coincident with the renaming of the
party they published a 25-point party
program so to come to the question about
whether they were socialist or not
what's interesting is if you go through
these 25 points
uh that by my count
14 of those points focus on economic
matters
and then
11 of those points focus on other kinds
of matters how do you define uh
the nation appropriately should we be
dictatorially or parliamentary should
there be freedom of the press right and
so on but those 14 points and i would
put it to you
as a hypothesis
that if you read those 14 points
every socialist in the world would agree
with those 14 points
and that's a strong claim but uh check
it out and verify it for yourself at
wikipedia any number of other points
that are out there the policies with
respect to uh government price controls
nationalizing of certain uh key industry
uh uh uh and various kinds of controls
all the way down uh the the development
of uh government education and running
of the education system and so on you
just go right through the list it's all
socialism so i think what we're very
quickly we're going to get into though
is the debates over
you know how pure does your socialism
have to be
and does your socialism need to be
nested in a broader context or should
the socialism be the economic socialism
be fundamental so what the nazis are
pushing for is not going to be a marxist
version of socialism it's not going to
be a saint simonian version of socialism
or a furrier version of socialism or a
russowian version of socialism they
thought of themselves as socialists uh
and they thought themselves as better
socialists than the other socialists
that are out there so i would just leave
it at this point uh but if the the
debates strike me as very similar to
the catholics and the protestants and
the eastern orthodox
all having their centuries-long
arguments about who the real christians
are
uh it's the exact same sort of thing
they are socialists but there are lots
of different subspecies of socialism the
nazis are in that mix so why do we call
them the far right stephen
i think that comes out of uh that's
always struck me as a north american is
extraordinarily alien because when i was
a young guy i was educated in in
classical liberalism and so what left
and right mean is always culturally
specific to the political landscape
right so in canada right where i grew up
right what what was left and what was
right uh it means something different
than what was left in what is right in
in the united states and so on so uh i
think what you have to do for that is to
go back to the 19th century european
intellectual context and this is the
continental european because the the
british are somewhat exceptional on this
score here and what you find when you
look at the intellectual landscape
particularly by the time you get into
central europe is
right is a nationalistic form of
collectivism that you are part of this
ethnic group uh so you're a german
you're an austrian you're a schwabian or
whatever it is that you happen to be
that's the first and foremost thing
about your identity and with that comes
a certain language a certain number of
cultural traditions with a certain
number of religion so you are formed
your your nation is formed by all of
those that that constellation of group
membership identities and then that
people on the left have a more economic
understanding of your collective
identity so it's two versions of
collectivism one making fundamental
economic matters the other making
fundamental cultural matters as well and
so that's the debate now obviously they
disagree with each other uh on all sorts
of applied issues but what they do agree
with each other is
on the collectivism and that and they
are all
anti-individualistic and they also agree
with each other
that there's not going to be
a harmonious negotiated resolution of
the differences between these various
groups the conflict is deep and
fundamental and as a result that
conflict is going to be resolved by
power not by means of uh negotiation
agreement democratic and parliamentary
procedures and so forth it has to be
ultimately through revolution fighting
and and suppression of the of the other
group so
all right and stephen i always want to
say anytime you use right or left or
even liberal and conservative now uh
they're almost useless in contemporary
discourse unless it's a journalistic
shorthand and you know that you're
talking for the british context or the
japanese context or the russian context
makes sense uh and like you say we all
fall into that trap very often nowadays
i think you know in our conversations
the other thing i was going to ask you
and this is just us getting some of the
definitions out of the way really
is uh i think in the modern culture we
use the terms fascist and nazi
interchangeably
yeah can can you explain what that is
all about and the differences and what
we should know about that
yeah that's another yeah fascinating
issue because uh uh you know technically
and the academic in me wants to say that
you should not distinguish national
socialist and fascists that they do have
ideological membership inclusion
criteria but they also have historical
differences that that should be
important so
uh the point about fascism is that
fascism originated in italy and the most
important person here obviously is
benito mussolini uh but the important
thing is here this is often overlooked
is that
mussolini was a man of the left until he
was 35 years old a man of the far left
until he was 35 years old he was a card
carrying marxist
right and saw himself as working with
the unions organizing the workers that
the marxist picture of the world was by
and large correct and what we needed to
do was bring marxism to
italy it and it that uh that was it's
not uh an ethnic rivalry but rather it's
a class rivalry that it's the the
italian workers versus the italian
capitalists and it's the same so it's
all of that that line that we know he
was a true believer until he was in his
middle 30s and then world war one
happened
and world war one he was shocked to
realize was that the italian workers
whom he'd been arguing his whole life
and working with them said they're being
oppressed by the capitalists and that
world war one was on the marxist
analysis supposed to be this capitalist
war and it really what should happen is
that all of the workers and all of the
different nations around the world
should get together and overthrow their
their marks as or their capitalist
oppressors and so forth and bring about
the revolution that instead what was
happening was that first and foremost in
all of the italian workers minds was
their loyalty to
being italian they thought of themselves
as part of the italian ethnic group and
they're against the french and they're
against the germans and they're against
all of the other ethnic groups so what
mussolini realized was that uh this idea
that economic interests come first was
wrong
and that it's a different call activity
that needs to be stressed and so what he
wanted to argue is rather than
international socialism that workers of
the world should be uniting what we need
to do is have socialism for the italian
people and it's going to have a
different flavor than the socialism for
the french people and the socialism for
the german people and that's where the
label fascism comes from and it's a
it's partly hearkening back to ancient
rome where you take a bunch of rods and
you bind them together with a cord you
can't bend them you know any individual
rod you can bend and snap pretty easily
but a bunch of them together so we need
to come together as a collectivity as an
individual you are part of this
collectivity you're supposed to serve
this collectivity even sacrifice
yourself and die for this collectivity
but the right call activity is the
italian cultural group so it's socialism
for italians and that's what fascism is
and the same story needs to be told here
mussolini was a very well-read man
and he was a very articulate man he made
a living as a journalist and as an
editor of a newspaper for for for many
years he knew the ins and outs of
arguing all of the fine points of
theoretical detail from his years as a
marxist
and he was working with first-rate
philosophers in italian universities
gentilly and others who were
reading nietzsche reading marks reading
hegel reading con it's all the same guys
again and then taking that philosophical
framework putting it through an italian
collectivist lens and outcomes fascism
with with with mussolini at the leader
so if fascism is italian socialism
uh then
when we go a little bit north right then
what we have is hitler and the others
arguing well we need to have national
socialism for
germans so they are siblings uh in
collectivist uh socialist nationalist
universe
absolutely fascinating stephen so uh
coming forward to the present day
because in our culture you know when
brexit and trump happened everyone
started calling everyone a nazi and a
fascist now with covid vice versa and
you know even i jokingly as a comedian
sometimes you know i see a later story
out of austria you know making vaccines
man the tree and i am sort of tempted to
make the historical connection as well
so how do we you know everyone seems to
be worried about the rise of of this
thing
how do we know because what i'm hearing
is a thread through everything you're
saying is collectivism it's all about
the collective is more important than
the individual and therefore maybe you
don't have the right to take or not take
the vaccine because your body isn't
quite yours as an individual we the
collective need you to do something very
specific how do what would be the
telltale signs that nazism or fascism is
making a comeback yeah well i would say
uh yeah that's a hard question so i
think very quickly
you need to get to know
the person you are labeling
well as an individual and i think just
taking one data point you know that the
person is in favor of a more
authoritarian political policy on this
particular issue is not enough to bring
out the big gun i think it's fair to say
you know if someone is in favor of say
mandatory covid vaccinations for
children before they can go into school
well that clearly is an authoritarian
measure and the right label to use at
that point is to say that is an
authoritarian measure but then to go on
to say that that is a marxist measure or
a nazi measure or a fascist measure
that's going to then bring in a whole
bunch of other baggage that rest of that
baggage might be appropriate but you
would need to know that that particular
individual advocating that particular
program also signs on to by and large
the rest of that particular program if
you don't do that then i think you are
just engaging in name calling and and
doing cheap shots and that's a that's an
intellectual irresponsibility so it's
not just you know fascist and nazi and
so on uh you know
the same sort of accusations with
respect to calling someone a sexist or
calling someone a a racist uh because
you know their nuanced understanding of
these complicated issues is slightly
different from yours that's too much
cheap shot uh
you need to do your homework i also do
think with and this is the the liberal
tolerance coming out here treat people
as in individuals not as avatars for
various shadowy movements that are going
on there and just as we do in a court of
law you need to give that person a
chance to explain you need to know about
the person's broader context before you
uh you start using the condemnatory
language
stephen i remember talking to my
grandfather who volunteered to fight the
nazis and i remember when he was still
alive when i was a young boy having a
conversation with him
asking him why is it
that people
voted for hitler why was it that people
supported him and he said to me i always
remember this he said you have to
remember francis at the time
that
germany was in a really bad way
economically hitler was a working man's
friend
at the time is it is that a fair
statement to make stephen i think it is
a fair statement to make uh so
you know when you start asking about the
nature of the support for the national
socialists
uh the same sort of dynamics that we
would talk about right now in any
democratic republic and political
context an election is coming up and
then what your party strategists do very
quickly is they look at their
demographics and they start dividing
them into different groups and the
different groups do have different
interests and things that are more or
less important to them
so the nazis did have by the time we get
into the late 1920s and they're starting
to get increasingly number more votes
and then on into the 1930s things go up
and down
uh until they're successful in
1933 and they get the hitler appointed
the chancellor but it's uh it's
parliamentary politics and we have to
understand it that so a lot of people
are uh working uh week-to-week uh jobs
they are laborers and so that's a huge
demographic and so the question every
party is putting to itself is
uh how can we appeal to this demographic
appeal to their interests and make them
election promises so that they will vote
for us
and so the the nazis to a large extent
did see themselves as economic
socialists uh you know we haven't said
anything yet about
about uh goebbels uh aside from the fact
that he was highly educated but he loved
karl marx
and kind of channeled karl marx in in
much you know his um anti-capitalist
money and and and and interest is making
slaves of all of us we are friends of
the workers and so on so there's the
workers there's the teachers there's the
professors there's the newspaper people
there are uh you know people in all
different walks of life and you tailor
your program to appeal to as many people
as you possibly can in those groups so
people who are uh uh
workers uh uh that is by which we mean
shorthand tag manual workers whose
employment prospects are are somewhat
uncertain
uh you know things are going up and down
weimar germany uh you know it was was up
and down devastations obviously
following world war one uh vicissitudes
of the market and all kinds of
government controls that were going on
so it was not a stable comfortable place
to be to be employed and in that context
it's very easy to say we will give you
all sorts of goodies right and we've got
scapegoats uh so anytime you have a
problem these are the bad guys who are
causing all of your problems and so we
should hate those people and and vote
them out so the nazis like many other
groups are just were very clever at
putting together a package that was
appealing to
many people in that
that subgroup for whom economic matters
on a week-to-week basis are are very
important what's interesting is that
they saw themselves as being in direct
competition or competition with the
communist party
and if you follow and this is gets very
nitty gritty uh through the late part of
the 1920s and on into the early 1930s so
you go into specific neighborhoods in
berlin in germany in munich in hamburg
right and so on so working class
neighborhoods and what you find is in
this election in 1928
you know 80 of the workers are voting
for the communists
in the next election those same 80
percent are voting for the nazis and
then in the next election they switch
back to the communists and then to the
nazis they're going back and forth so
they're competing for exactly the same
turf and it becomes a matter of very
fine detail sometimes at the level of
personality politics you know this guy
was caught in bed with the wrong
the the wrong person's wife and so
we lose that particular election and so
forth or we're able to sweeten the
economic pot and make slightly more uh
economic promises than these guys are in
this election so they switch over and
vote for us
for us as well so i would say yes
absolutely your grandfather was right
economic interests do drive
elections significantly but i want to
say that's not the only issue and it's
perhaps not the most important issue
what were the most important issues that
that caused people to to vote for hitler
and for the 90s in 1933 and before that
well i think uh there were religious
issues there's there is the
the long
sordid history of anti-semitism in in
germany so whoever is most able to paint
the jews as bad people
as the poison in our midst and get
people riled up on uh on on religious
and anti-jew matters they're going to be
more successful in particular elections
and that's a that's a long-standing
issue uh and it's also striking that if
you look at the leading philosophers i'm
coming back to the philosophers again
kant hegel marx nietzsche to a lesser
extent they are all anti-semitic it's
shocking to those of us raised in the
liberal tradition you know we read
john john locke about tolerance back in
the
1690s arguing that we should be
tolerating the jews right and and adam
smith and just becomes part of our our
ethos that we might disagree with them
religiously and see them their cultural
habits is different from us but they're
human beings living their lives and they
should have the same rights as their as
the rest of us you don't find that in
germany there's a very tiny classical
liberal movement there and all of the
big uh the big names are anti-semitic in
in various degrees so that religious
matters the the long-standing ethnic
feuds right what do you think about the
russians what do you think about the
french what do you think about the
english
do you see them
to the extent that international
commerce or international politics is is
the dominant set of issues in this
particular particular ethnic cycle you
know the same way that right now you
know we need to be worried about the
russians or we need to be worried about
the chinese it's easy to get that
whipped up into
national consciousness and get a swing
vote based on that particular issue
uh uh i think it also is important is
what people are reading in the
newspapers
and if you've got a generation of
journalists who've gone to uh graduated
from high school and gone on to
university they absorb a certain
ideological view of the world and that
comes out in their in their newspaper so
what are the newspaper editors deciding
and so on uh the other group would be
and this is another shocking one when i
started reading about this is what are
people learning not in universities but
in primary schools
and one of the striking things in the
1930s
slightly before the nazis came to power
the if you look at all of the teachers
teaching in primary schools all up and
down germany
and you look at their political party
memberships
there were more teachers who were
members of the nazi party prior to
hitler coming to power than any other
party in germany
so uh it's a cultural revolution so
people are absorbing this this ideology
in schools they're reading about it in
their newspapers in many cases they're
hearing it in their sermons and then
when they have their you know their
after dinner conversations or after work
conversations at the pub over a few
beers and so on uh and then the union
organizers come in and they preach a
certain economic message you get it from
all angles and i think ultimately that's
what shapes people so it's not going to
be one thing it's the whole ideological
package that's put together
hey francis do you like books i only
like comics that's why my favorite
publication is the guardian it's true no
one does satire and parody like they do
so did you have a brilliant satirical
book for me yes it's a book by one of
our fans scott biceno and it's called
identity crisis it has been described as
1984 with jokes so it is like the
guardian no no no it's intentionally
funny set in present day northwest
london it tracks the personal journey of
cocksure city boy dave dalston through a
period in which the government has
decided to define everyone by their ego
profile by a document called the id card
it's a rollercoaster ride through
cancellation redemption and spiritual
enlightenment the author has been a fan
of trigonometry from the very start and
he has drawn a lot of inspiration from
its conversations so if you're a fan of
trigonometry then you're going to love
this book anton we are getting our 10
aren't we
check it out on amazon guys the link is
in the description below
at what point was it that hitler decided
that he needed to spread nazism around
the world or was that always
a a goal for him
yeah
well uh that's that's an interesting
question so what i would say is here i
think hitler is
channeling the great philosophers
and what you find in i'll just site two
here it's just uh hegel and marx hegel
in the early part of the 1800s but he
becomes perhaps the dominant philosopher
of the early part of the 19th century
and then mark's writing in the middle
part of the 19th century and his uh his
influence starts to be manifested more
in the early part of the 20th century
after the success of the the revolution
in in russia but what do both of those
have in common despite the fact that
they are somewhat different in some of
their metaphysics and their epistemology
some of their value frameworks and so on
what you find in hegel is the idea that
the state
is the manifestation of a kind of divine
providence on earth
and that through the state
uh all individuals need to realize their
personal identity
to serve the state and to be willing to
be sacrificed for the state so that the
state can realize its divine
providential mission and it's going to
happen you know divine providence
happens right no matter what you or i as
individuals say
and there are certain great men who come
along who are chosen by these divine
providential forces to embody the state
and thereby to embody the entire culture
to bring that culture forward to the
next stage
and it just so happens that germany is
of all of the cultures around the world
the one that is most evolved and that
germany has this providential mission to
take all of the world in a certain
direction now that's a two-minute
summary of hegelian philosophy and
political philosophy but imagine
yourself as a young thoughtful well-read
politically ambitious german reading
hegel
what is your inspiration going to be
right well
i want to be the embodiment of the state
and to take germany in the in the in the
right direction so all of that
collectivity and a little bit of
religion and might makes right at the
international level all comes to be fine
and uh it necessarily has to be a
conflictual war-like fashion that's
going to going to bring this going to
bring this about so uh heidegger another
german philosopher of the 1920s carl
schmidt probably the most intelligent
legal mind uh also a phd
uh all of them are reading hegel and
they're arguing that german has this
special germany rather has this special
special mission and both of them end up
being very strong supporters of national
socialism and providing the intellectual
and academic ammunition for it now you
find the same thing in marxism uh in a
more left-wing or or economically
socialist version right that the whole
world is in this economic clash of of of
cultures of and in classes and that it's
a die-hard struggle of alienation and
exploitation
and it's only going to be through
this violent revolution
that
this manifestation of the proper way of
society being organized is going to
happen and there needs to be a
dictatorship of the proletariat
a small vanguard of individuals who
embody their class interests and know
what is best for the society as a whole
who are willing to
ram things through and make the
revolution happen no matter how bloody
that it gets so whether you're absorbing
a more right-wing hegelian understanding
or a left-wing marxist understanding by
the time you get to these guys
that's the political zeitgeist
uh i and i was gonna ask stephen we've
got a few minutes left before we ask you
our final question uh moving
slightly beyond the nazis specifically
in into the philosophical underpinnings
of that again coming back to
collectivism and liberalism one of the
things we've explored on the show
somewhat is
the
the lack of meaning in in modern society
that we have and the absence perhaps of
religion but also just the whole liberal
world seems to create that sort of uh
you know we are all an island of one
person in some way that's how it can
feel sometimes to a lot of people on the
other hand collectivism you've just
charted you know the terrible ways it
can lead people to think and behave
so is there some kind of
golden middle or is it just classical
liberalism all the way like
is there is there a good way to organize
society
yeah well i don't think there's a golden
middle when you frame things that way
i'm uh liberal all the way down
the way down in the in the in the
philosophy but you're right i mean it is
a very good criticism of liberalism to
say
that fundamentally you are on your own
that you are an individual you have your
life and you are a free agent you have
the right to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness now what's
distinctive about liberalism though is
to say that
making your life is a do it yourself
projects not to say that you won't be
very social and other people won't help
you and you'll have wonderful support
networks right and so forth but there is
a bottom line responsibility that
liberalism puts
on each individual
and then we do find a big divide among
among
individuals in a liberal society those
who are
grateful
who are energized who are delighted by
the fact that i am a free agent and i
can do whatever i want with my life and
i'm going to go out and do something
pretty special with it versus those who
feel that as a burden
as a weight
as i'm not sure that i'm up to the task
and that sounds a little bit scary
and for that psychological type i'm just
going to call it a psychological type
right now i do think the collectivisms
are going to be more psychologically
attractive setting aside any of the any
of the intellectuals because what all of
the collectivisms do is to say
there is a ready-made group with a
ready-made set of values and there is
this set of institutions
uh
where all of it is worked out and all
you need to do is just be part of this
group and we will provide meaning for
you and give you a cause and mobilize
all of your
your energies in a certain direction
so the idea then is for the collectivism
it's going to be through
politics
and absorbing yourself into
uh pre-existing
social institutions that you are going
to find meaning
uh and that's going to be very
comfortable to uh to a large number of
people and the individuals uh in on the
in the liberal tradition they're given a
lot of hard work to say you have to
make your life it's not something that
you can just take off the shelf or or or
be absorbed into
so i think that really is the great
challenge for any sort of liberal
philosophy broadly conceived is to say
that we need when we are dealing with
young people to be able to raise people
who are by the by the time they're
adults they're welcoming and able to
take on that great challenge of going
forth into the world and making their
own meaningful life and i think the
reason why there are so many uh
animistic
and and atomistic individuals floating
around the liberal society is that we've
not done a very good job of that
and the way you talk about mobilizing
groups and giving groups a sense of
purpose and you know people can identify
themselves by their group
it sounds a little bit like identity
politics you know what we see now
yeah
yeah this this is not a cheap shot but
this is
2021. if you were to go back to germany
in 1921
it's exactly the same thing only only
the names have changed it is a form of
identity politics and notice that the
the point here is not first and foremost
political it's what is your identity
am i an individual i have my own mind i
can form my character and my values and
it's up to me as an individual to get up
off the sofa and go out into the world
and make
my life into what i wanted to be that's
my core identity or is it the case that
i
as an individual i'm born into certain
groups and i have a ready-made
individual a ready-made identity that i
can just put on like a suit of clothes
and uh that's who i am and my values and
my goals and what i'm supposed to do in
my place in society is all worked out
that's my collectivized identity
so i i
you know if you think about the the
ethnic versions of this um
so
you guys are again i'll tell you some
some british examples here but you know
you say so
part of your identity is to be british
and then you can say you know we are the
nation of shakespeare
and john milton uh and just you know
saying those names you you sit up a
little straighter in your chair and you
you feel some measure of pride that's a
point that needs to be unpacked very
carefully you know so was it the fact
that you just happened to be born in
this particular place in the world
that because other people who were born
in that particular place in the world
centuries ago did some amazing things
that that makes you a better person that
you don't need to do anything additional
just by virtue of being british you are
special i think that's a danger
i think the right way to do that then is
to say uh yes shakespeare was great john
milton was great and why i can feel
pride of that is not due to the
happenstance of my birth but i as an
individual have become an educated
person
and i have learned to appreciate
shakespeare and john milton and all of
the others uh who have done some pretty
amazing things and so i'm the kind of
person who is worthy of
being related to in some way shakespeare
so it's got to be tied to your
individual achievement not just
happenstance of birth
see it's really really fascinating
particularly the point that francis
brings up about uh collectivism and
collectivist ideas in modern society and
i take your point that the job of
educators like you and i'm sure you do a
brilliant job at it is to prepare people
not to have to get an off-the-shelf
solution yeah uh it to to to living a
fulfilling life and making meaning for
themselves
what do we do
with the fact that there's a lot of
people who who who want the
off-the-shelf thing and that that's
that's you know we failed as you say to
provide that how do we manage that in
the current political moment
yeah
well i uh i think we have to think for
the long term right by the time people
are 25 30 35 40 and so on
uh they can change they can reform you
know people who are are alcoholics who
have various kinds of addictions they
can change but it's a rare person who
does so
uh and my particular interests are in
university aged people but in this last
year or so i'm doing a lot in in
philosophy of education and applied
philosophy of education because
you know this is not an original point
to me by any stretch
how we educate children is the the most
important long-term thing
so if for example uh you know i've
written on on on this if from day one
for example we teach children to be
afraid of the world
that we're killing all of the animals
and everything is going to be poison and
you probably aren't going to see age 25.
if we start teaching people that at age
5 then we're not going to raise a
generation of people with the emotional
resilience to handle
important say environmental challenges
right that's an indoctrination education
method that sabotages people's emotional
resilience if we dumb down mathematics
and science because we say it's too hard
for boys or it's too hard for girls or
it's too hard for members of this racial
or ethnic group and so we do math for
dummies so to speak at a very early age
and intellectually by the time we are
graduating so-called high school
graduates we're going to be putting out
millions of people who do not have the
intellectual resilience in order to be
able to take on the challenges of modern
technological and scientific society
much less the broader intellectual
project so my view is that formal
education
there are some islands of excellences
and some places that are pretty good but
the average has been very low and in
some cases it has been outright sabotage
of people young people's intellectual
and emotional capacity for taking on
modern living so that's where i think we
need to be focusing our our education
reforming
uh existing educational institutions and
the one thing that i am encouraged by is
the large number of people who are
recognizing the low to abysmal results
uh in much of mainstream education and
who are engaging in literally thousands
and thousands of different
entrepreneurial experiments to try
different educational models so by the
time we have this conversation hopefully
20 years from now we're uh we're dealing
with a different young people
demographic
stephen it's been absolutely wonderful
thank you so much for coming on the show
the hour has quite literally flown by uh
yeah
but uh we always end our
interviews with the same question which
is what's the one thing we're not
talking about but we really should be uh
well i
i i would just return to the point uh
that i just made but uh make it in in
slightly different form
uh
i'm trying not to be one of those
curmudgeonly old professors talking
about about kids these days
but i uh i i do
notice a generational shift in the young
people who show up in my in my
university classes
uh and it's not just the young women
it's also the young men
uh by and large
it does seem that the young women are
coming out of high school a little
better prepared for university life than
the young men are
but i'm still
a little bit discouraged
that
we're not talking enough about what's
going on in the high schools
uh how we are
kind of minting people
uh
with a degree that to a large extent is
not actually
an honest credential there's a huge
amount of dishonesty saying
we give you this diploma we send you
forth you are ready for adult life when
everybody knows that is is not true
we uh we we revere educators teachers
we've given them a huge amount of money
uh and there's been a certain amount of
benevolence on the part of everybody to
give them the benefit of the doubt on
all sorts of scores but i think we do
need to have an honest reckoning about
what's actually going on in a serious
effort at reform
fantastic stephen hicks thank you so
much for coming back i really recommend
people check out not only the
documentary that we mentioned but also
you've written a number of books and i
know you've got a couple yeah yeah
the book that came out of the
documentary so let me do a commercial
plug for that one
nietzsche and the nazis uh you came you
came very well prepared stephen and of
course we look forward to having you
back on the show when the newbies it
would be a pleasure let's plan on it
thanks a lot thank you great
we're going to ask you a couple of extra
questions from not from us but better
ones from our local supporters but in
the meantime we're going to say goodbye
to our audience thank you so much for
watching and listening we'll see you
very soon with another brilliant
interview like this one or raw show all
of them go out 7pm uk time and if you
like your trigonometry on the go it's
also available as a podcast take care
and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our local community using the
link below